wormholes excite us as shortcuts through
space but in a special case they could
also be shortcuts Through Time
Einstein's equations showed that mass
has an impact on the space and time
around it a black hole is an intense
concentration of mass and would distort
the space and time around itself so much
that time slows to a stop at the Horizon
of the black hole if we got lucky and
found a wormhole that had its other end
near a black hole then traveling through
it would spit us out in the past to a
region where time runs slower than back
home in theory a very clever version of
our future selves might be able to tie
one end of a wormhole to a spaceship and
take it wherever they wanted but right
now we can't manipulate SpaceTime in
this way and the existence of wormholes
is pretty shaky at best